and going to read out the results of the
election of a Member of Parliament cert
to serve in the UK Parliament Adrienne
shots constituency the electorate was 64
thousand 146 the total votes cast were
38 thousand and 49 and the percentage
Paul was 59.3% I for jokes has returning
officer for the United Kingdom
Parliament general election in a dream
and shot constituency hereby give notice
that the total number of what's called
for each candidate at the election was
as followers Jennifer married and Ellen
Scottish conservative and unionist eight
thousand year 213 Neil Greer Scottish
National Party SNP fourteen thousand two
hundred and ninety-one
Helen McFarland Scottish Labour Party
14090 six
[Applause]
and you would make McRobert scholarship
Liberal Democrats 802 the dibala clear
was rejected with 47 total votes cast
thirty-eight thousand and forty nine and
I hereby declare that the candidate
elected to serve in a UK United Kingdom
Parliament for Airdrie and shots
constituency is neil gray
[Applause]
thank you very much Paul I'd like to
first of all thank you very much to your
team for the way that this election has
been handled throughout the last six or
seven weeks and the comb this evening as
well I'd also like to thank the police
and all the other services involved in
running this election I'd like to pay
tribute to the other candidates who
stood in this election and there was a
very good campaign and I congratulate
them all and on their result I'd like to
thank my election team led so ably by
Graham Russell my election agent who has
been a stalwart for the SNP
for years and also to my office staff
led by Adam Robinson you guys have been
fantastic you've put in the work for the
last two years and I really really
appreciate everything that you have done
there's no getting away from the fact
that tonight is a difficult night for
the SNP we've suffered some difficult
losses but I'm confident I know that
every smpm he elected to Westminster
will go down there with her constituents
interests at heart
we'll continue fighting hard for our
constituents and the people of Scotland
and doing all we can to make Scotland a
fairer and more prosperous place thank
you very much
[Music]
you